of the three branches of the US
government the judicial branch is the
one that is least bound by public
opinion Supreme Court justices aren't
elected they're appointed and they serve
for life or until they decide to retire
usually justices serve on the court for
many years after the end of the term of
the president who appointed them one
Justice William O Douglas was appointed
by Franklin Delano Roosevelt in 1939 and
didn't retire until 1975 when Gerald
Ford was president can you imagine how
much changed during his tenure on the
court the framers designed things this
way so that the Supreme Court justices
can be independent consulting the
Constitution and precedent to decide
whether laws and executive actions are
permissible without having to worry
about keeping the public happy to get
reelected but this also means that it's
not unusual that the Supreme Court makes
decisions that the public the president
or members of Congress don't like Brown
vs. Board of Education in 1954 is a good
example white Southerners resisted the
ruling refusing to integrate segregated
public schools although it wasn't
popular with the majority population of
the states that it most affected the
ruling protecting minority rights in
Brown versus Board was made possible by
the Independence of the judiciary in
that case the Supreme Court had the
backing of presidents Dwight Eisenhower
and John F Kennedy who sent federal
troops into the south to enforce the
ruling even though the court is
independent it's still important that it
maintains its legitimacy in the eyes of
the public so that citizens believe that
the court is impartial and that it's
possible to challenge the other branches
through the actions of the court to
maintain its legitimacy justices on the
court are careful not to give the
appearance of favoring one political
party over another by ruling too often
for or against one party's policies but
what happens when the President or
Congress doesn't support the Supreme
Court's rulings what measures can they
take to affect the courts decisions
there are three main ways that we'll
talk about in this video
future appointments to the court
changing the court's jurisdiction and
refusing to implement the courts
decisions one of the ways that
presidents can influence the court is by
appointing justices presidents tend to
nominate Supreme Court justices who
share their interpretation of the
Constitution so their appointments
change the ideological composition of
the court for example President Richard
Nixon appointed four justices to the
Supreme Court that altered the courts
ideological leaning he assured in a
transition from a liberal Court under
Chief Justice Earl Warren to a more
conservative Court under Chief Justice
Warren burger Congress can also
influence the court by changing the
number of justices today we accept that
there are nine justices on the Supreme
Court but article 3 of the Constitution
doesn't actually specify how many
justices are on the court over time
there have been as few as six and as
many as 10 there have been 9 since
Congress passed the Judiciary Act of
1861 limited seats in the 1860s then in
the 1930s Franklin Roosevelt proposed
adding more seats to the Supreme Court
so that it's ideological balance would
move in favor of his New Deal
legislation so although the number of
justices on the court hasn't actually
changed in 150 years Congress does
retain the power to adjust that number
another way that Congress can influence
the Supreme Court is by changing its
jurisdiction or the field of Authority
that it has to hear and decide cases
there are two places in the Constitution
that say that Congress can do this
article 1 section 8 which says that
Congress has the power to constitute
tribunals inferior to the Supreme Court
and article 3 section 1 which says that
judicial power shall be vested in the
Supreme Court and such inferior courts
as the Congress may from time to time
ordain and establish so Congress may add
new federal courts spice
letting up an existing district or
subtract them by combining districts
Congress may also pass legislation
stripping the supreme court's
jurisdiction to hear certain types of
cases on appeal some recent examples of
Congress attempting to strip the supreme
court of jurisdiction concern the
detainees at Guantanamo Bay detention
camp in Cuba in the mid-2000s the
detainees petitioned the Supreme Court
to review whether their detention was
legal and Congress passed two laws
stripping detainees of the right to
petition courts for review the Supreme
Court overturned both of those laws the
last way that the other branches can
push back against a court decision is by
refusing to implement it or by doing as
little as possible to implement it
remember the court itself has no
enforcement power it has to rely on the
executive branch to enforce its rulings
so what happens when the president
disagrees with a ruling in most cases
presidents enforce the Supreme Court's
rulings whether they like them or not
seeing it as part of their duty to
uphold the government but in rare cases
a president might choose not to enforce
a court ruling especially if their party
controls Congress an early example of
this was in 1808 when the Supreme Court
ruled Thomas Jefferson's embargo act the
one with a famous Oh grab me cartoon was
unconstitutional Jefferson instructed
customs agents to keep on enforcing the
embargo and they did so the important
takeaway here is that even though the
Supreme Court determines the law of the
land the system of checks and balances
still applies to it Congress and the
president have several ways to influence
the courts power present and future